good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is scp-1000 three object
class Keter special containment
procedures the foundation currently has
ten instances of scp-1000 3-2 designated
scp-1000 3 - 2 - 8 - k in its possession
all of which are held in separate
heavily guarded high-security cells at
bio research area 13 all personnel at
bio research area 13 are to undergo
compulsory testing for signs of scp-1000
3 infection personnel wishing to access
scp-1000 3 - 2 JFK may only do so for
the express purpose of research must
have a level 4 security clearance and
must have written permission from o5e
beforehand they are to wear biohazard
suits when entering scp-1000 3 - 2 - 8 k
cells and go through an intensive
disinfection process afterwards no
animals of the order Carnivora are to be
allowed at bio research area 13 under
any circumstances description SCP 1003 -
one is an adult tapeworm of the species
a kind of caucus granulosus known for
causing hydatid disease like others of
its species SCP 1003 - one inhabits the
small intestines of carnivores typically
canids where it produces eggs that are
passed in the hosts feces bag can
survive up to the years in the outside
environment when the eggs enter the
gastrointestinal tract of a human
subject nearby designated the
intermediate host by a consumption of
contaminated food they hatch into larvae
which burrow into the hosts tissues it
is at this stage that scp-1000 threes
anomalous properties begin to manifest
instead of developing into cysts the
larvae developed in
two creatures which resemble human
embryos hereby designated scp-1000 3-2
the vast majority of scp-1000 3-2
specimens die before they have a chance
to develop those that survive are
usually those that are embedded in
nutrient-rich tissue such as hepatic
tissue as they develop they absorb
nutrients from the surrounding tissue
which often causes problems for the
intermediate host a CP 1003 - 2's
development mostly follows the pattern
of a normal human prenatal development
but at a faster rate by eight weeks it
is as mature as a three-week old neonate
although it is similar in size to an 8
week old embryo approximately 13 to 16
centimeters once it has reached this
stage it will actively consume the
intermediate host from within using
sharp hooked teeth as CP 1003 - 2 growth
is accelerated to an even greater extent
as it is doing this by the time it has
fully consumed the intermediate host
usually after about minutes or so it
will have developed into a child the
physical age of the child ranges from 10
months to 11 years depending on the mass
of the intermediate host though in
extreme cases where the intermediate
host is morbidly obese it can be as high
as 13 to 15 years once scp-1000 3 - 2 is
finished it will lose its hooked teeth
along with its cannibalistic tendencies
from where on it will be functionally
indistinguishable from a human in every
aspect with no knowledge or memory of
having been a parasite it will even
possess learned skills for example
language that will be expected of a
child its apparent age despite there
being no way it could have learned them
instances of scp-1000 3 - 2 are usually
taken into whorfin ages and sometimes
adopted by foster parents there are only
anomalous properties at this stage are
that their DNA is somehow still
identical to that of a kind of caucus
granulosus and that their bodily fluids
including sweat and saliva contained
tapeworm protists kollek's
which infect carnivores and develop into
scp-1000 3-1 thus continuing the cycle
addendum testing of scp-1000 3 with
animals such as cattle and sheep which
are common intermediate hosts of a kind
of caucus granulosus have found that its
anomalous properties only manifest in
humans and in all other cases it's life
cycle is normal and causes hydatid
disease in the intermediate host ok that
was a very short one today I'm sure
you're pleased to hear thank you all
very much for listening even though it
wasn't that hard and I will see you all
at a later date
goodbye I don't know I sung that goodbye
I need a break I would like to give a
special thank you to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
Tiber Ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support is greatly
appreciated
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos on smaller
cool stuff as well as it patreon.com
forward slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you